nate is with us in raleigh north
carolina hi nate welcome to the
ramsey show what's up hey thanks for
taking my call
sure how can i help so i'm graduating
nursing school
in a couple of months i'm sitting on two
job offers right now
one of them is working days and the
other is nights with primarily
covet patients but that job pays about
ten thousand more per year
i'm trying to save up for graduate
school which is going to be about 120
000
and i'm planning to work two to three
years before that i'm trying to see if
it's worth taking
the harder job to make that extra twenty
thirty thousand
i thought it was ten thousand well i'm
gonna be working for two or three years
oh 23 000 over a two to three year
period i see
correct uh will either one of these uh
places pay for your education if you
want to go back
uh it's through the same company but
it's not
it's not significant okay what's your
degree in
it's nursing okay and so what are you
you're an rn or lpn or what
i'll be graduating with our end yes okay
and what are they paying you so
one would be about 60 000 and the other
would be about 70.
and you classified the night one as the
more difficult one
why is that nate um it's kind of working
on a unit that's
pretty much overrun with covid patients
so just wearing all that gear
all the time uh-huh
okay all right do you do you have
overtime available with either
we can usually get we can usually work
four to five shifts a week if we need to
yeah or if you wanted to right well yeah
and so if you were to do that four to
five extra shifts over that would be a
lot more than
ten thousand dollars yeah correct
i was just kind of going with a base
assuming 40 hour work weeks
yeah but if i'm working overnight and
i'm wearing gear and i'm exhausted so i
can't take the other shifts
that offsets correct
yeah i think you work more of a normal
life other than other than the fact or
you take the normal job
and you just work more and you're going
to make a lot more than an extra 10
doing that
that you could not have made if you were
exhausted from overnight and wearing the
gear that's right
it's up to you i think you're definitely
i think you're on the phone from there
for sure
yeah yeah because you got to factor in
nate the quality of life
also right i mean just how you're going
to be as you're pursuing this to be able
to want to go to grad school
obviously you have the heart to serve
people i would go with that day job and
take as much overtime as possible yeah
i think i think i would too and the
other thing i'm going to do
is um our ends are always in demand but
right now there's
a huge demand i don't necessarily want
you to take either one of these if you
haven't done some more shopping
about what's out there i would love for
you to find a place that would pay for
your school
and give you 60 or more and give you
overtime potential
so i am slightly confined to my state
because like
the state of north carolina helps pay
off certain amounts of debt if we work
there for
x amount of time so how much is that
seven thousand
plus seven thousand a year for how long
that's
this is just gonna be for my first year
okay that's just nice yeah but if you
give up if you give up a job that was
gonna pay you 80
that's right and and you got seven more
that was not a good trade
yeah and that's just what's called
golden handcuffs yeah
and that's like the whole student loan
forgiveness plan and these debt-free
i'll take the seven if i can get it but
don't take a if you can if you can move
across the state line into georgia or
whatever and and or tennessee uh
whichever state line i don't care
virginia and you can make 80.
yeah plus over time plus they pay your
stuff
then then stink and give up the seven
yeah give me the moving truck
that that's the thing so let's get uh
i'm afraid you've constricted yourself
uh on a
false boundary here oh i agree uh be
careful with that one
hey man thank you for the call i'm proud
of you man you got a good career field
you're always going to have work and
you're always going to have more work
than you
possibly want you know chris people do
that sometimes
um we place the wrong
you know it's almost like it's almost
like a distraction like look over there
so you can run away you know that kind
of thing right and so it's a look over
there that's seven thousand and you run
away from 25 000 over here
yeah and you do that sometimes with
benefits package yep and you go
oh i don't give a benefits what's it
worth right 50
a month 600 a year and you walked away
from a 15 000
increase in pay because you don't give
up the benefits you know it's just
you know because you but you never
really do the actual math
you just go have this emotional reaction
and it's it's like a distraction like
look over there it really is and so
what we just did with nate was break
down and talk dollar amounts
and i want to encourage you all out
there there are always more options than
what appear
in the here and now and whenever you
start to say i only can do this or this
that's not true those are the two things
you've thought about
so do do yourself a favor seek wise
counsel go talk to some people that have
done some stuff
some people that have lived some things
and you'll find you have a few other
options available well when we're
teaching
leaders for instance in entre leadership
that are running businesses
we teach them decision-making skills and
one of the best decision making skills
you can
always do is to have lots and lots of
options
yep there's a lot of power in options
you have a higher probability of making
the right decision
but if you say oh i've got two options a
and b and both of them suck i just got
to choose between suck and double suck
you know and that's just a bad choice i
mean you have to change something right
to change that mindset but no you really
do in his case that wasn't what he was
facing he didn't have two bad options
but
you just if you've got 15 different
things laying on the table
instead of three your worst case
scenario is you get confused
your best case scenario is you're gonna
have better options yeah no then you've
got power
and you can go back to well i like this
other place better but they're 5 000
off and you go back and go guys if
you'll meet this other offer i'll take
your
deal that's right you know and you throw
in paying for my grad school or whatever
it is i mean you can negotiate
when you've got the you know it gives
you power because you know you can go do
the other thing
that's right and you're not demanding
you're asking you're having a
conversation